an Ohio man may be released today from
the hospital after being found nearly a
week after he disappeared on the slopes
of an active volcano in Washington state
Matthew Matthew Matheny was reported
missing last Thursday after his car was
discovered on a Mount st. Helens trail
the 40 year old was found yesterday
about two and a half miles from there
Matheny told friends he stayed alive by
eating berries and bees Don Dahler shows
us the hikers incredible survival story
Don good morning good morning
Matthew Matheny went missing and one of
the most remote parts of the country
wearing little more than a t-shirt and
flip-flops and while the odds may have
been stacked against him the former Boy
Scout was found in far better shape than
anyone ever expected I am just in such
shock and such relief Matthew Matheny's
friends celebrated his rescue I'm really
still kind of in disbelief and just
happy I can't wait to see him after days
of searching their friend had finally
been found he has been a trooper
obviously I thought I thought we might
not see him again Matheny's ordeal began
last Thursday when he borrowed a
friend's car and drove to a popular
hiking area near Mount st. Helens when
he didn't return his friends reported
him missing he basically said he
stumbled out into the canyon and lost
his pack I actually found his sunglasses
in as a clue his car was parked here
volunteer rescue team spent six days
combing through steep canyons and
shouting Matthews name until he was
found he was miles around the other side
of the mountain and he'd hiked fit he
was closer to actually summers bivouac
than he would be from here so he had
covered a lot of ground Matheny told
friends he survived by eating berries
and even bees he got stung at 40 50
times and every time he'd get stung you
just smacking need it Matheny's parents
who traveled to Washington from Ohio
told reporters that it's no surprise
that their son a one-time Boy Scout who
is now a nurse was able to survive he
was a boy scout and one of my friends
texted me earlier and said that's a heck
of a way to get your Eagle
Matheny was airlifted to an area
hospital where he's listed in
satisfactory condition he was being
treated for dehydration after not having
water for nearly a week officials say if
Matheny had spent just one more night on
the mountain he could have died I'm glad
they can all laugh about it that his mom
has her son back and she can laugh but
clearly dawn he wasn't planning to be
there long with flip-flops no you don't
go hiking and evidently he one of them
at least broke so he was barefoot I
found him and and that area is so rugged
you imagine you can get lost take when I
get lost here the broadcast center yeah
to get lost like in five minutes there
so it was not maybe a good idea maybe
it's time to invest in a satellite phone
there we go right